[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنوا اتفاق استئناف
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايران بعد سبع سنوات من القطيعه
بواسطه الصينيه وصف بالصفعه المزدوجه التي
تلقتها الولايات المتحده لما حمله اتفاق
الخصمين من دلالات والصفعه ثانيه لم تقل
اهميه ارتبطت بتعاظم الدور الصيني في
الشرق الاوسط التطور اللافت دفع بالكثير
من الصحف الامريكيه لتخصيص مساحات تناولت
الحدث وما حمله من دلالات على حساب ضعف
النفوذ الامريكي في تلك المنطقه حسب ما
رات صحيفه نيويورك
صحيفه واشنطن هي كذلك هذا تطور بانه
اختراق كبير لتنافس مرير لطالما قسم شرق
الاوسط ولفتت الى فشل محاولات اداره
الرئيس باراك اوباما اصلاح العلاقات بين
السعوديه وايران كما ركزت صحيفه على ان
وصفه دبلوماسيه الصيني البارز وانجي هي
بانه انتصار للحوار وانتصار للسلام يرسل
اشاره واضحه وفق الصحيفه لكنها بالتاكيد
تختلف عن تصريح الرئيس الامريكي بايدن
خلال زيارته للسعوديه في يوليو الماضي بان
واشنطن لن تبتعد ولن تترك فراغا كي تملاه
الصين او روسيا او ايران
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان تحسن علاقات
اسرائيل والعرب افضل للجميع
الناطق باسم مجلس الامن القومي في البيت
الابيض جون كيربي نرحب بالاتفاق
الدبلوماسيه وينبغي رؤيه ما اذا كانت
ايران ستفي بالتزاماتها
المسؤول الكبير السابق في الولايات
المتحده والامم المتحده دور الصين هو
الجانب الاهم في الاتفاقيه ليس اعاده فتح
السفارات بعد ست سنوات من القطيعه سيتم
تفسير ذلك وربما هذا هو الصحيح على انه
صفعه لاداره بايدن وكدليل على ان الصين هي
القوه الصاعده
نعود من جديد الى ضيوفي اعود لكم
نناقشه منذ قليل
نود فهم بكين الى اي مدى هي معنيه بانجاح
هذا الاتفاق ليس فقط بهذه الخطوه الاولى
باعاده العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ولكن بانجاح
بقيه النقاط وهي نقاط بالغه الاهميه وبلغت
الحساسيه كذلك ومن بينها التعاون الامني
الذي تود اعاده احياءه مع كل الاطراف
والذي انشئ في 2001 هل الصين يمكن ان تكون
ضامن حقيقي لتحقيق هذه النقاط
اعتقد من الوضع على نفوذ السين يتوسع
بسرعه في منهاج الشرق الاوسط لكن سين قد
اكدت ايضا
لا تتنافس مع الولايات المتحده على
الخيمنه
ولكن من المستحيل عدم ردي على واشنطن
لفتره طويله كان احد
الاسباب المهمه
للفضاء في شرق الاوسط والاستمرار الدول
الاخرى في اثاره الصله صراعات داخليه في
هذه المنهاجات وكما تم تغيير الحقوق
هل الصين لديها ملفات للضغط يعني لما
نتحدث عن ضمانات نتحدث ملفات ضغط ليس يعني
يعني مش ملفات ضغط في الاتجاه السلبي
للكلمه ولكن ملفات ضغط يمكن ان تكون
اقتصاديه ممكن ان تكون حسابات سياسيه هل
الصين تمتلك هذه الملفات القويه لتضعها
امام الاطراف ولتدفع
بمحاوله تثبيت النقاط الباقيه
اعتقد ان
لديها الهدف
السلميه في هذه المنطقه وخلق البيئه
للمجتمع دولي كما قد
في بشان
الحزبي الاوكرانيه
واصدرت الصين
المبالغه السلميه
بشان اوكرانيا وكما
المبادئ مبادئ او سياسه الخارجيه في شرق
الاوسط هي عدم تداخل في شؤون داخليه لدول
في هذه المنطقه وعدم اختيار
الاعترافي في في نزاعات في شركه وانخفاض
على علاقات الدبلوماسيه المتوازنه مع احد
في الواقع
ان هناك تكتم سيد تشاو حتى في القراءات
وحتى في محاوله فهم الوضع وكانه هناك تكتم
مثل معهدناه في الواقع هي كذلك تتعامل
بطريقه فيها الكثير من الكتمان ولكن
سيدتوني ما رايك هل تمتلك الصين شيء
تفتقده واشنطن منذ قليل كنت تحدثت عن ان
المشكله التي تمثل في واشنطن لا تمثل في
الاداره الامريكيه بشكل عام بقدر ما هي
متمثله في الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
وكانك القيت باصابع الانتقاد على اداره
بايدن
هي تعود المساله الى اداره باراك اوباما
لا يزال يعني النفوس المؤثر الاكبر في
سياسات هذه الاداره والحزب الديمقراطي
عموما يعني عندما نتحدث عن دور ضامن
بالصين نحن نتحدث عن شيء لم يحصل بعد ما
في سابقا لهذا الموضوع يعني هذا النوع من
اذا بدك تمنيات او تحليلات عقلانيه يعني
عم نحكي مثلا انه لديها رافعات ضغط لديها
علاقات جيده لديها مصالح اقتصاديه وحتى
مصالح استراتيجيه ليس فقط ضد الولايات
المتعلمه وضد الهند انما في في ايضا تثبيت
حصولها على المفصل من الخليج والقطع
الضغوط عليها في اسيا والى هنا هذا كله
جيد انما لا ليس هناك من سابقه هذه كلها
التحاليل العقلانيه العلاقه مع الولايات
المتحده
يعني لماذا عقود كانت كانت العلاقه على
اسس عقلانيه استراتيجيه عقلانيه الا
وباما
والسياسه العقلانيه وراح في
استقلالي في السياسه اتجاه المنطقه واتجاه
ايران وبالتالي هذا هو السبب يعني انه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه غياب هذا التحول
واعاده التواضع الذي بدا مع براك اوباما
ولا يزال مستمر
ديمقراطيه ولكنه انقطع لفتره قصيره مع
اداره ترامب
هذا اعاده تواضع وهذا الدخول نوع من عدم
الاستقرار او الثبات في السياسه الامريكيه
بسبب هذا
التحول بالسياسه الديمقراطيه هذا ما دفع
المملكه العربيه الى البحث عن خيارات
لانه كما قلت ليس هناك اي صادق لا نعرف
كيف ستتصرف الصين يعني هناك فقط تحليلات
وتخلينات وان كانت عقلانيه لكن العقلانيه
ليست كل شيء يعني يمكن ان ياتي شخص
ويطلب الطاوله كليا صحيح او حدث مثلا
ويقلب الطاوله نتمنى ايجابيا ولكن دكتور
عبد العزيز هل تعتبر حضرتك بان واشنطن من
المنتفعين ام من المتضررين
اولا من دخول الصين كوسيط وثانيا من
التقارب السعودي الايراني
يعني هنالك روايات مختلفه او وجهات نظر
مختلفه لكن اذا افترضنا ان الولايات
المتحده تدعي ان حريصه على الامن
والاستقرار في المملكه فوجود اتفاق مثل
هذا سوف يساهم ويعزز مفهوم الامن الاقليمي
في المنطقه ويخفف من الضغوط لكن اسرائيل
ربما تكون الخاسر الاكبر لانه يعني
نتنياهو حينما جاء الى السلطه كانت وعود
بانه سوف يحاول ان يتعامل مع هذا الملف
النووي بشكل كبير في ايران زياره مستشار
الامن القومي الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن
ومحاوله المفاهمه فيما يتعلق بالبرنامج
النووي واحتماليات توجيه ضربات عسكريه
لايران الان تبدا تنخفض لانه حينما تتحسن
علاقه مع المملكه والمملكه اكدت اليوم على
حتى في تصريح سموزي الخارجيه على قضيه
ضروره ان تلتزم ايران باتفاق منظمه الطاقه
الدوليه والوصول الى اتفاق مهم جدا في هذا
لانه مصلحه المملكه ودول الخليج بشكل هو
وجود اتفاق نووي وليس عدم وجود لانه وجود
الاتفاق ايا كان هو افضل بكثير من عدم
ولكن نريد اتفاق يضمن قضيه اساسيه بالنسبه
لنا اولا
الايه تتمكن ايران من الوصول الى برنامج
عسكري نووي يحدد امن المنطقه والنقطه
الثانيه ان لا تغفل قضايا المنطقه
الاقليميه التي تطرحها المنطقه واللي هي
ذكرها ايضا وزير الخارجيه اليوم في حديث
صحيفه الشكل الاوسط فهذه القضايا الاساسيه
اما امريكا اذا هي تريد الامن والاستقرار
في المنطقه وهذا ما تقوله فمن باب اولى ان
ترحب بهذا الشيء ربما هو التساؤل الحقيقي
الكبير ساعود لك للتساؤل كبير هذا ما
تقوله ولكن هل هذا ما تريده فعلا لان
البعض يقول بان الوضع المتوتر في المنطقه
قد يخدم المصالح الامريكيه قد تضع هذه
الملفات
ملفات ضغط بين الفتره والاخرى
يعني هو بالتاكيد
الولايات المتحده لها مصالح عسكريه كبيره
ولها يعني ايضا مصالح فيما يتعلق يعني في
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه امريكا استغلت
هذا الوضع لبيع الغاز باسعار عاليه فدائما
الدول تحاول ان تحرص على مصالحها الذي يجب
ان تتاكد منه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
انها لم تعد السياسه التقليديه القديمه هي
القائمه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
المملكه تريد ان تحسن علاقتها مع كافه
الاطراف لم تمانع من اعاده ترتيب العلاقه
مع تركيا بعد زياره الرئيس اردوغان
للمملكه وبعد زياره سمول العهد الى الى
تركيا هي ايضا رحبت
بالمفاهمه حول موضوع سوريا وعودتها الى
الجامعه العربيه ضمن شروط اساسيه وشروط
الاساسيه واضحه كانت بالنسبه للمملكه هي
ايضا انفتحت على العوده الدبلوماسيه
المباشره مع ايران فطبعا المملكه اليوم
تتصرف من منطلق ربما من الولايات المتحده
ابقاء حاله التوتر مفيده لها اقتصاديا او
لبعض شركات او لكذا ولكن ما ننسى الولايات
المتحده عندك خمسين الف جندي في المنطقه
الولايات المتحده عندها مجموعه قواعد
عسكريه مهمه في المنطقه الولايات المتحده
انسحبت من افغانستان دون ان تبلغ احد بهذا
الانسحاب وبهذه الطريقه هي اعاده تشكيل
قواته في المنطقه فتركت علامه استفهام
اساسيه وكبيره حول مدى ثقه المنطقه في
التصرف الامريكي من فتره الرئيس اوباما
والخطوط الحمراء التي وضعها في سوريا الى
مرحله الرئيس بايدن الذي الذي شال
الحوثيين من اول اسبوع استلم في السلطه في
الولايات المتحده وعدم قدرته في الوصول
الى اتفاق حقيقي فيما يتعلق بالموضوع
النووي النقطه الاخرى المهمه احب اقول لك
اياها بس العفو لو سمحتي لي اليوم كان
هنالك مؤشر ايجابي في ايران على فكره وهو
تحسن سعر العمله بمقدار 10% بمجرد ان
الاعلان ان العلاقه سوف تعود وهذا مؤشر
مهم يعطيك انطباع مهم ايضا لدى الشعب
الايراني انه يرى ان العلاقه الجيده مع
المملكه والمستقره يسهم في تحسن الاقتصاد
بشكل اساسي وقوي في هذا المؤشرات ايضا يجب
ان تؤخذ في الاعتبار والاهم من ذلك كيف
سوف يتصرف الحرس الثوري بعد هذا الاتفاق
الذي وقع كيف سوف يحترم الالتزامات التي
تحسن من الوضع دون ان لانه ايران في عزله
على فكره واحد مصالح ايران الاساسيه هو
الخروج من هذه العزله وعليها ضغوط محليه
عليها ضغوط اقتصاديه عليها ضغوط اجتماعيه
عليها ضغوط دول جوار ايضا بالنسبه للصين
هي بحاجه الى ايران لانه ايران لديها حدود
كبيره تحتاجها في افغانستان تحتاجها في
خطوط الانابيب تحتاج في اشياء اخرى يعني
ثانيه فهذا ايضا مهم بالنسبه له حديثك عن
ارتفاع قيمه سعر العمله الايرانيه مهم
كذلك لانه قادر ان يكون يعني نقطه مهمه
وخاصه مغريه لاستكمال تنفيذ بقيه النقاط
فقط قبل المرور المحور الثالث تعليقك سيد
توني
هناك احساس بانك لا تتوافق مع من يقول بان
هناك
ضرر من هذا التقارب الايراني السعودي
بالنسبه لواشنطن هكذا قرات في تعبيراتك
لا بالنسبه خلينا نكون فهمانين شو هي
سياسه باراك اوباما واداره بايد الحليب من
الاول كانت اداره بي استدارتها نحو ايران
اداره باراك اوباما والان اداره بايدن هي
تسعى الى ان يعني
ان تعيد ايران من عزلتها وان تخرطها مع
بقيه
المنطقه وانت تتغاض
ى واحد وان تثبت مكاسبها وخلينا نرجع هون
يعني هلا يعني كان في بالتوصيفات اللي
قراتوها بالتقرير عن كيف الصحف اللي هي
كلها تتبع يعني نقاط التعليق الحزب
الديمقراطي بامريكا انه عن نقاط الصراع
السعودي الايراني اي صرافه سعودي ايراني
خارج عن اليمن وين في صراع سعودي ايران
يعني كلها هذه الملفات اللي عم تنحكى فيها
اولا المملكه العربيه ادت انه هي ما عندها
اي يعني اهتمام بما يحصل في لبنان بسوريا
بعد في مسائل قائمه يعني هي عارضت العوده
الى الج في مسائل انما هي على الارض يعني
ما في صراع
ليست مهتمه بما يحدث في داخل اللبناني
صحيح بان وزير الخارجيه لما سئل عن
الموضوع وزير الخارجيه السعودي قال بان
هذا الموضوع لبناني لبناني فليتفق
اللبنانيون اولا ونحن سنرحب باي تقارب هذا
لا يعني بان ليس هناك اهتمام لا بالموضوع
السوري ولا باللبناني ولا ببقيه الملفات
سيتوني صحيح
لا انا عم بقول هذا الكلام دبلوماسي انه
خلي اللبنانيه يزبطه
الخارجيه سيكون كلام دبلوماسي رسمي
يعني انه يعني مثلا كان في ضغوط من اداره
اوباما اداره على المملكه لاعاده الفتح
التمويل والا ما هنالك وانخراط وال
ة يعني هاي مش شغلتنا ولا اهتمامنا لانه
بس هون نرجع للنقطه الاساسي ليش الولايات
المتحده تحتها الاداره تحديدا
وسياسه اوباما ليش تسعى الى اخراط المملكه
العربيه بتمويل يعني مساحات هي لديها نفوذ
اكبر ايراني فيها لانه بنرجع بنقول يعني
لا انا نقطه عدم الاتفاق يعني مع الدكتور
بنفكر هو انه
اداره اوباما بايدن خليها نسميها هي ابدا
التقارب السعودي الايراني هذا ما تسعى
اليه كانت بالاساس انما المشكله اللي هي
البيت القصيده هو اللي ذكره بتعليقه
هو السعوديه فيما يتعلق بالملف اليمني
والحوثيين كما قال وفيما يتعلق بالاتفاق
النووي وهذه نقطه اساسيه صرنا على على
علاقات قوسين من انه ايران انه يصير يمكن
عندها سلاح نووي ساعتها شو بيصير شو راح
يكون دور الصين هل تستطيع الصين ان تقوم
ضامن في هذه السياق اذا اذا استطاعت ايران
ان ان يعني تحصل على سلاح نووي معين قبل
الحصول على هذا على فكره سيكون محل نقاش
الجزء الثالث لانكم كما تعلموا ضيوفي
الكرام هناك تساؤلات حول هذا القرن وان
كان سيسمى بالقرن الصيني الى اي مدى الصين
قادره كذلك على بسط نفوذها على
فرض دورها في هذه المرحله ساعود لكم ولكن
بعد لحظات بعد ان نتوقف مع فاصل قصير